Biden was in Israel on a Wednesday
meeting with the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and he made some remarks after
that meeting let's play those remarks
and get your analysis of what he's
saying I come to Israel with a single
message You're Not Alone we're going to
make sure we have what you have what you
need to protect your people to defend
your nation for decades we've ensured
Israel's qualitative military Edge and
later this week I'm going to ask the
United States Congress for unprecedented
support package for Israel's defense I
understand and many Americans
understand you can't look at what has
happened here to your mothers your
fathers your
grandparents Sons daughters children
even babies and not scream out for
justice justice must be
done but I caution this while you feel
that rage
don't be consumed by it after 9/11 we
were enraged in the United States while
we sought Justice and got Justice we
also made mistakes the vast majority of
Palestinians are not
Hamas Hamas does not represent the
Palestinian people Palestinian people
are suffering greatly as well we mourn
the loss of innocent Palestinian lives
like the entire world I was outraged and
saddened by the enormous loss of life
yesterday in the hospital on
Gaza based on the information we've seen
to date it appears a result of an errant
rocket fired by a terrorist group in
Gaza today I asked the Israeli cabinet I
met with for some time this morning to
agree to the delivery of life-saving
humanitarian assistance to civilians in
Gaza today I'm also announcing $100
million in new US funding for
humanitarian assistance in both Gaza and
the West Bank this money will support
more than 1 million displaced and
conflict affected Palestinians in
including emergency needs in Gaza must
keep pursuing peace must keep pursuing a
path so that Israel and the Palestinian
people can both live safely in Security
in dignity and in
peace for me that means a two-state
solution so there's a lot packed into
that Montage of highlights but what I
hear Biden saying is that America will
keep funding Israel's military defense
that he's working to provide Aid to
Palestinians telling Israel not to let
rage Cloud their wartime judgment and
that he still believes in a two-state
solution what are your reactions to
Biden's comments and what are your
critiques of his overall diplomatic
approach I think that Biden says a lot
of very valid things in this interview I
think it is quite helpful that he has
raised the example of our own conduct
after 9/11 and acknowledge mistakes and
missteps that were taken and excesses
that were
taken uh I think it's also valid for him
of course to validate that they're
suffering on both sides here's where I
have a problem on a rhetorical level
many of the things that ven is saying in
my view are correct and are the right
things to
say on a practical level are we actually
doing those things
he says that he believes in the
two-state solution the United States is
long abandoned actually putting any
pressure to make sure that there's an
achievement towards that it was quite
interesting in the New York Times
article that Tom fredman wrote when the
Biden Administration was trying to get a
normalization deal between Israel and
the Saudis and what was in it for the
Palestinians was not a compromise that
would give them the state that they've
been seeking for more than 70 years now
but rather Pathway to keep the option
the dream alive so we've gone from
actually promising to achieve a
two-state solution to promising to
achieve the survival of the dream of a
two-state solution so we're not doing
those things that the president is
saying and and again the the
normalization deal was premised on the
idea that you can just ignore the
Palestinians that you can as Jared
Kushner said because this is all built
on what Trump's uh Abram Accord was
that you can move beyond the Palestinian
issue not even a desire and ambition to
resolve it but you can move Beyond it
because that conflict has now become so
contained that we don't have to bother
trying to resolve it in essence and in
practice that has been US policy the
rhetoric has been that we still believe
in a two-state solution etc etc part of
the reason why we still say that we do
is because it sounds good and the minute
we say that we don't when we recognize
that we have also helped kill the
pathway for a two-state solution that's
when we would have a very active uh
crisis even in short of what Hamas did
here so we keep on saying it but it's a
pretense game we really do have to shift
being serious about this particularly
mindful of the fact that that
instability has a significant likelihood
of sucking the United States into a
conflict that we should not be involved
in military so say a two-state solution
gets pursued what indication do we have
that Hamas would in any way agree to
that play this out for me a little bit
well first of all Hamas is not in
control of the West Bank they're in
control
of sure agree in terms of like like the
way tensions are right now why do we
think that that is what would be
happening well you're saying that right
now but why didn't we do it three four
weeks ago why didn't we do it during
this entire period in which we didn't
have this instead we just gave lip
service to the two-state solution and
contined to pursue a policy that
essentially buried it in the ground
you're quite right that under the
current circumstances it's going to be
extremely difficult to just get any
diplomacy going uh but that is
nevertheless ultimately where we have to
end up uh and that and these moments are
the extremely difficult moments in which
you have to set your Ambitions a little
bit more realistically it has to be
about deescalation ceasefire once you
have that it creates a bit of a pause
that creates political momentum to
escalate it towards a bigger political
agenda then move towards a real
negotiation to actually end this
conflict it's not so that tomorrow there
can be a meeting with all of these
parties at the table and they would
actually talk about this issue there's
several preliminary steps that need to
be taken if we don't take them however
we will never get to the point of
actually having the real diplomacy and
we will also not have the deescalation
that can keep the United States out of
this War I have to assume that this such
a negotiation would involve the
Palestinian Authority cooperating with
Israel and partners to facilitate the
complete expulsion of Hamas because
there's no way that we're coming out of
this on the heels of a brutal terrorist
attack giving a with you know giving a
two-state solute giving an in an
independent Palestine that it that would
just send the message I I would assume
that terrorist um works and acceptable
method of
negotiation I think the pathway here is
to First recognize that there needs to
be uh a negotiation uh with the
Palestinian Authority who by the way
incidentally is lacking significant
legitimacy amongst Palestinians as well
uh the majority of Palestinians in the
West Bank tend to see the Palestinian
Authority essentially having taken over
the management of the occupation and a
collaborating with the Israelis in that
kind so it's not as if you know U
there's a partner there that has the
backing of its population that further
complicates matters but I can see a
pathway in which there is first a
negotiation that that actually gets
serious about a two-state solution and
such a two solution has to deal with
what the United States used to call
illegal uh settlements on Palestinian
territory we have significantly soft in
our language and in our opposition to
that even though those are violations of
international law and even they have
made uh prospects of a two-state
solution far far less likely we have
green light at that which again is in
practice we're moving in a direction of
making a two-state solution uh next to
Impossible but rhetorically we still
talk about it as if that is our goal but
that that sort of dodges the question
that Z that Zach just asked right like
there would be this problem of if you
know ultimately we there there was a
two-state solution that was pursued and
and and granted and gotten that would
send the message I mean you you have to
fully Stamp Out Hamas before that no no
hold on let me let me get clarification
what do you mean that there was a
two-stage solution um that was there no
no no I'm saying if if there were to be
a two-state solution in the aftermath of
this surely one of the stipulations
would have to be that Hamas can in no
way exercise any power within this
region because otherwise there is this
message of you know you commit
terroristic acts and get rewarded for
your efforts right like certainly uh
yeah no I I sorry I better understand
the question now thank
you uh so uh first of all let's let's
recognize that in the past negotiations
the West Bank and Gaza often times have
been separated let's also recognize that
if there actually is a valid process
that is genuinely moving towards a
two-state solution guess what that does
it delegitimizes Hamas Hamas is managing
to get a degree of support precisely
because there is no diplomacy precisely
because there is no uh the
implementation of the measures that
Israel was supposed to do were never
implemented and instead we've seen an
increase of settlement activity and the
de facto annexation of Palestinian
territory so there's a clear perception
in the region that that diplomacy did
not yield what it was supposed to do and
then that further gives legitimacy and
support for a rejectionist organization
like himas who was opposed to that
process from the outset if you actually
truly want to get rid of that type of a
radicalism by being able to have an a
genuine process that is genuinely
seeking a solution that's the best way
of weakening Hamas and then after that
then you know that dynamic in and of
itself can create new opportunities in
uh in Gaza um uh that can help get the
Palestinian population themselves there
get rid of Hamas and get a leadership
that is willing to particip participate
in the process but right now given the
track record of uh how negotiations have
been used to expand settlements that is
right now not not something that has a
lot of buyers amongst the Palestinians
and this is what I'm saying we have to
completely reverse this if we truly want
to get a resolution here the Assumption
had been this is okay there's never
going to be a major amount of violence
and destabilization here because we have
managed to contain um uh the
Palestinians we have managed to contain
their aspirations we have ai and all of
this technology they can never do
anything else so the cost of just going
on with the status quo and the
occupation is manageable and that was
fundamentally disproval hey thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with TR parsey about whether the US can
and should deescalate things in the
Middle East you can watch another clip
right here or the full conversation over
here